mesdames et messieurs le rêve devient
réalité
france est convaincu qu'il existe des
monstres doté de pouvoirs surnaturels
ce sera son canot pour hitler une bande
de créatures surhumaine à ses ordres que
lui seul pourra commander
ses yeux rien ne pourra nous séparer ça
pas même la guerre
je ne tuerai personnes à la guerre comme
à la guerre doit te servir de thé
pouvoir c'est pas des pouvoirs
c'est une malédiction
bienvenue
[Musique]
l'eau pour voir son produit
j'ai vu notre futur
monstres seront notre salut
une jeune fille très spécial
[Musique]
tu as un pouvoir immense
j'vais venu m'inscrire à l'examen des
soins
ça fait 12 ans que tu le passes ça fait
deux ans que tu échoues jamais tous
s'intéressent beaucoup des globules
blancs et son bien propre homogène et le
cholestérol et la montée en flèche
bon bien d'arriver au festival électro
maroco ce soir
vous avez dormi 18 heures
j'ai pu diagnostiquer une fracture du
coccyx dans votre état vous ne pouvez
pas prendre l'avion abdelkader vous
apportera assistance à domicile 424
matin mais dix minutes chocolat en fait
c'est du placebo ce que tu leur donnes
nom qui est et
c'est l'heure du mbba il ya des heures
pour le vin si l'odeur qu'elle geller du
pain
c'est pas ça
dorénavant vous êtes en état
d'arrestation
ils veulent pas me rendre mon passeport
je peux même pas quitter le maroc
voulais pas m brasse électronique aussi
trop de n'a pas exclu peu restée avec
lui entre les gens que vous êtes ici
chez vous c'est ça le spi tel est évoqué
c'est pas d'avis pourquoi tu a sauté
alors je suis obligé
de la musique arabe mais d'une hausse de
vie
autant regarder strappé spécula au pla
avait comme il sera à
[Musique]
592 jour depuis le début de la fin nous
n'avons plus de gouvernement si ceux qui
ont survécu sont encore parmi nous
préparez vous assurez vous que vos armes
soient nettoyés et trouver un moyen de
vous protéger
tu dois fuir ne t'arrête pas tant que tu
n'es pas chez ben cours
tu ailles chez ben c'était l'un des
meilleurs agents du fbi que j'ai jamais
vue est devenue un survivalistes
pourquoi tu venu ici
ils m'ont trouvé
on va prendre la fille
et on va tuer le fermier
vous avez trop de secondes pour quitter
ma propriété tu peux à nous donner la
fille et me laisser réduire au ranch en
cendre ou b on te tuera et on prendra la
fille quand même
qui m la nuit risque d'être longue
c'est moi qui décide qui a le droit de
vivre ou de mourir moi vous entrez chez
moi vous essayez d'enlever cette fille
et vous essayez de me tuer en naissains
qui lui est tout seul
vous ai jamais demandé venu ici la fille
est à moi
elle est mon destin un destin sera ton
arrêt de mort
[Musique]
thomassin est malone avec c'est un jeu
très simple il ya des chasseurs
vous êtes la croix vous aurez une avance
de trois heures
thomaes c'est la fin de la route
pour moi je fais confortable
tous mettent malone est peut-être la
plus grande croix que vous n'affrontez
jamais lui est ce qu'on sera remboursé
sur hochtief pour moins d'une heure
c'est un ex flic accusé de meurtre
pendant un cambriolage qui a mal tourné
malone a défié la mort plus de fois que
la plupart de commandos marines
en d'autres termes
l'univers ne semble pas pouvoir les mini
t'es bon gamin je suis plus que bon je
suis le bacon lse du dimanche matin
vous conservez
ouais
c'est très bon et c'est ça et qu'est ce
que ça leur rapporte qu'est-ce qui se
passe l'étude touche gagnée et je vous
garanti la liberté
[Musique]
rappelons à malone qui est le chasseur
et qui est la proie
[Musique]
mais un homme comme lui n'aurait jamais
dû venir dans un endroit comme celui-ci
forcément la tête et thomas sol
alors ça fait quoi d'être chassés
[Musique]
les au château de champs pas
les tableaux à la rigueur passons des
enfants rose
vous êtes inconscient vous êtes courant
de ce qui s'est passé au vélodrome
d'hiver et si personne ne viendra les
chercher
au niveau venez pas avec nous tu devrais
vous voir dans votre nouvelle gâchette
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé
[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un
[Musique]
c'est comme ça
quant au couteau deux mois trois mois
ce nouveau lancement ce sont pas mes
enfants ce sont des enfants et au moins
on ne va pas les livrer ces salopards
m
passez pas la forêt
d'inquiéter j'y arriverai jamais
[Musique]
il ya les gens qui rêvent de changer et
il ya ceux qui comme moi décide de le
faire
lui c'est mon meilleur ami cadeaux
ils habitent à los angeles depuis 5 ans
ou trois ans et sexuellement décès des
bébés je fais du yoga les thérapies pour
finir sur des applications q quand même
j'ai trouvé lui pour demain soir ouais
c'est comme les crêpes et des lapins et
toujours phare est obligé de l'allemand
jette sur la première crèche
tu penses trop à la française monte
raquette c'est quand même un avion de
chasse jeunes comme un homme
sortir un peu la tisanerie à la con
voudrait laisser faire le destin si
cendrillon l'avait laissé faire les
destins passera encore en train de faire
des ménages chez sa belle-mère et à
parler des petites souris puis c'est
tellement génial d'être anonyme de
coucher avec un anonyme chauffe
c'est juste une autre façon d'être
spirituel en prêtant ses traits
physiques à ma main
le garçon assis à l'arrière c'est qui
repend me plaît à toutes les filles
retournant vers moi
affrontez
rien pourra jamais nous séparer
si on doit mourir demain
on reviendra tous les deux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait des jaloux vraiment horrible
je sais
ça me dit machine et ma vie sain tôt
[Musique]
tu m'as chine m
maintenant c'est nous qui sommes
inhumain